number two you're ugly your Virginia
doesn't count if you're ugly because
again blessing if your girl's face looks
like it was smashed in with a baseball
bat but she's a virgin or you get a girl
that's that's pretty hot but you know
like 10 20 bodies and that does anything
your virginity it's it's valuable but
it's not valuable if you're a will
you're ugly nobody's lining up to date
ugly fat chicks I don't make the rules
and so a lot of girls will be like I'm a
virgin I'm a virgin and it's like great
man but nobody's trying to no one's
trying to mess with you I was trying to
mess with you so it's like okay yeah you
turn down losers or trying to screw you
but like